the old world was you got you started a
brand that you thought paid to get even
a prayer of getting in now you build a
hundred million dollar business
direct-to-consumer and you're going in
with leverage this is one big game of
leverage you got your perspective
[Applause]
super excited that you're here excited
for this fireside chat we have plenty of
seats everybody's standing in back feel
free to fill out I apologize if I rush
out on a whim I gotta get to the airport
and I've learned my lesson on missing
flights in this town in the past so I'll
be following Dee rocks call and so let's
get into it so for context you know I
wrote the one of the first checks into
Birchbox and a lot of early kind of
2011-12 dtc movement and obviously in
the last 24 months because of the sheer
scale of the underpriced attention of
Facebook and Instagram and the amount of
capital that is available and the growth
of Shopify and Amazon all these macro
trends had led to an enormous growth of
direct consumer brands so I'm watching
that and obviously my great thesis of
creating vaynermedia was to buy a
nostalgic brand so I haven't been highly
motivated to do Jim shark or fashion OVA
or you know hims like that that's not
where my passion lies though I've been
seeing all the growth in parallel I had
to specific executives at vaynermedia
that were part of a team called the
office of the CEO so in theory a couple
years ago I realized how stretched I was
so I created a team to act like a chief
of staff and there was four of them and
after a year of it it just wasn't as
efficient you know I moved to one chief
of staff which has been working much
better but I had these you know multiple
executives that were super talented two
of them john Troutman and mate Schroder
who are my partners in empathy wine have
been with me since they were interns in
my wine business before vaynermedia and
then came to Boehner John had left and
worked for a distributor unit for a year
and a half and came back so as an
entrepreneur we're making this macro
decision on the Boehner
side I'm sitting with these incredible
human assets which is really kind of the
KPI of the whole Vayner thing to begin
with there's this incredible push of DTC
and as a third layer I'm weirdly missing
wine for the first time right when you
do something for 20 years and it's like
the only thing you're passionate about
you get burned out and so when I left
Wine Library to do Lehner it was so
refreshing and I was excited to not even
think about wine and then a couple years
later was fun because I started looking
at wine like a consumer you know my
whole life I'd go out to a restaurant
like they're making a ton of money on
this and this wine sucks and all that
kind of stuff and so that got fun and it
started becoming fun again nobody was
doing anything super crazy there were
some wine clubs that were doing
incredibly well but there was no
purebred direct-to-consumer brand at the
kind of scale so that's why it happened
we're off to an incredible start we've
sold almost two million dollars worth of
inventory in the first six months
without spending any media dollars all
off organic against my brand we did that
as a strategy to see if we could glean
insights at scale for my audience to
make us deploy the cat the media even in
a better way the a/b testing against
Gary fans versus wine drinkers as a
whole and so the next year for empathy
is gonna be really exciting because I
think we're really now gonna act like a
brand more so than the leverage of a
personal brand liaison you mentioned
that actually aces find it more than a
media plan and what that looks like she
wants to Instagram I you know the funny
part is I'm not sure and we launched it
everywhere right you might have saw it
on Instagram but we put on YouTube and
podcast and then Twitter and LinkedIn
and email and you know we're pretty
excited that goes as many platforms as
possible to bring as much value here I
think one thing for everybody to think
about with direct to consumer brands is
to understand I set up earlier the
phenomenon on the consumer side of why
it's happening there's a very important
thing I said very quickly and I'll say
it again there's so much capital in the
world today that B C's have to deploy it
that's how they live
and one thing that everybody really
needs to realize about some of these
incredible brands that we all love on
Instagram or pre-roll YouTube or
wherever you see them is most of them
are actually underwater they're raising
so much capital so they can play a game
where their customer acquisition is
thirty one dollars but their margin on
that is 19 so there are 12 bucks
underwater
our clients at vaynermedia for example
or established businesses that are held
accountable to Wall Street can't do that
and so there's some incredible things
that are going on with these brands but
if tomorrow
the global economy decides to start the
process in the other direction 98
percent of the brands that we think are
crushing it will be out of business
because they won't be able to raise the
next round there are two underwater
their math doesn't work on customer
acquisition and profitability and it's
game [ __ ] over and so we need to have
a little bit better of a conversation to
have more of a practical conversation
around DTC's brands to realize many of
the ones that we put on a pedestal I
always say to my friends it doesn't take
a hero to lose money every month and I
think we need to be thoughtful that a
lot of these brands are not building
actual brand they're they're really CAC
and LTV conversion sales machines that
are arbitrage against influencers or
Instagram and they need to be very
thoughtful about building brand right
now because when [ __ ] hits the fan it
will be brand that will get them through
the dark time see friends to build brand
bang you know we're seeing a lot like
our role in traditional TV ads release
I think it's a huge mistake and I think
you're seeing it because they're wasting
money and they don't care and I think
that they the biggest Delta is we we
literally what's amazing to watch these
brands go so happy on traditional
above-the-line creative is that the
great case study of modern creative
comes in the form of Dollar Shave Club
the Dollar Shave Club video is this
generations just do it or where's the
beef it really is an iconic piece of
creative that birthed the billion dollar
brand the number one mistake that
directed consumer brands at scale are
making right now is not creating
long-form video on Facebook and YouTube
to build brand equity and that's how I
see it and I think there are couple
brands that are actually for that matter
purple mattress if you if you if you
nerd on this stuff you should go look at
what purple mattress is doing as a
company versus what Casper is doing as a
company right one is very hardcore dtc
and is growing as a leader Casper the
purple is creating a lot of creative
$180,000 production and creative
execution risk of making a funny video a
video that makes you cry a video that
makes you think if you hit that your CAC
and LTV numbers get really good real
fast because now you're creating a brand
and and that's the ultimate goal well it
means that the Facebook's of the world
the googles of the world are getting
more of their I mean it's crazy you have
two gals in middle of nowhere starting a
direct-to-consumer peanut butter brand
and two years later spending more money
on Facebook and Instagram than like if
you go talk to Facebook executives that
run their business they are getting way
bigger budgets from companies you've
never heard of and that is probably my
favorite thing that's kind of going on
literally literally when you look at the
top spenders on these platforms it will
blow your mind literally a brand you've
never heard of and that's because one
trades on sales data
another one trades on internal MMMs or
reporting compact your other point is
there danger in building your whole band
on one platform yes
you become one-dimensional and a
one-dimensional fighter is vulnerable
and Lamia now instead of just like
making a fun statement let me add a
little bit to that look anytime you're
looking for growth you know this is
actually a fun way to create some
clarity about how I think about the
world
I don't hate traditional media I think
over a long period of time it became
overpriced I actually love outdoor for
example about 1 gets seen you know not
everybody's looking at their phone every
second and if you really like I love UI
and UX in real life so I like outdoor
quite a bit I just like to buy it when
it's remanent and I could buy it for one
month for two thousand bucks instead of
the twenty four thousand they want when
you buy it for six month conch so to me
the danger of being one-dimensional is
why would you want to be one-dimensional
right you're you're gonna squeeze the
crap out of one through and you've
squeezed all the orange juice out of the
orange but there's a grapefruit right
here and you should start them and even
if the grapefruits small there's still
juice in there and so to me I think
about overpriced and under priced
attention and as real-estate prices come
down in a soft economy and more internet
business inevitably it's gonna turn and
storefronts are gonna be a good buy so
there's a bunch of companies that are
bout to go out of business because they
side big leases seven years ago didn't
factor in EECOM and they're underwater
they'll go demand for retail everyone's
a headline reader like don't buy retail
it's the internet so what will happen is
the man will go down so retail in two or
three years
especially if the Connie get soft is
gonna be a [ __ ] deal for these brands
that get walk-in trap I mean still
everybody here bought something in a
store recently so yeah there's just no
reason to be one-dimensional what do you
think
specifically detailed species hotties
Indians just another big deal with this
awesome
I'm into it I think you expand your
business you've got the leverage as a DC
brand you know the old world was you got
you started a brand and you [ __ ] paid
to get even a prayer of getting in now
you build a hundred million dollar
business direct-to-consumer and you're
going in with leverage this is one big
game of leverage so your recent campaign
with k-swiss you are out I saw you thank
you thank you that's very much a branded
piece by yourself I'd imagine where do
you see that going you know so just to
catch up everybody this week we launched
the fourth collaboration with k-swiss
and what we decide to do this time was
do an above you know I love eating my
own dog food some yelling and everybody
for not doing longer form brand videos
to drive their business and so I said
then I'll do it for this so I and then I
said what's underpriced attention
influencers are underpriced so I reached
out to a huge slew of influencers who
follow me and offer to pay them and we
made a very long form video at Vayner
productions I was very uninvolved
obviously besides sitting and answering
questions which they used some of it in
the video but very little me in
comparison to everything else we made a
long-form video that a bunch of
influencers posted for a witness and it
was just a brand piece it was just kind
of more similar to the stuff I normally
put out but more production value no
different than the Dwyane Wade Budweiser
piece we did or the Maxwell piece we
didn't so and the impact on sales was
extraordinary it it drastically
outperformed clouds and dirt which was
more sales more of that approach and so
you can imagine and and here's the best
part back to not caring about outdoor
radio or television I didn't care if it
was gonna fail because I know creative
as the variable of success but it worked
extremely well
yeah I mean look I apologize for cutting
you up if you're gonna make content you
need people to feel something when it's
done whether they laugh they cry they
think like you know I mean that was that
was the most important if the video
sucks [ __ ] we would have sold sneakers
you know and so we went with a brand
approach on digital because like I said
in some meetings today with some of the
leaders I believed that digital Facebook
Instagram YouTube LinkedIn is the place
to build brand not do lower funnel sales
I think that's the place to do two three
four five six minute videos because I
think that's the place where people are
consuming information it's not super
complicated and once everybody wraps
their head around it it's so funny to
see the creative landscape push against
this because they put the emotion and
the ideology of TVC on a pedestal
meanwhile every creative on earth would
much rather have 2 minutes and 13
seconds to tell a story than 30 or at
least the appropriate amount of time to
tell the story versus being combined to
a 30 or 15 or a 6 a huge role
influencers by nature are creative and
distribution media all in the price of
one with word-of-mouth affirmation and
co-signing they're the great deal of our
industry yet there's enormous scrutiny
around it because people like headline
reading instead of being practitioners
Oh
it's a great question we're just having
this debate upstairs like look what you
measure against is so imperative right
you know to me if I'm a business I'm
trying to suffocate the [ __ ] out of
everything I do
to prove to me that it's driving so for
example if I'm a retailer which I grew
up once so this one comes natural to me
I want to do branded outdoor with
actually a product and offering and not
offer that product and offering anywhere
else in the world so that I've
suffocated the variables to understand
that that was the channel that drove the
behavior in my 713 stores against a
forty nine thousand dollar production
cost and a six hundred thirty seven
thousand dollar outdoor media spend and
the fact that we don't do that over time
made me realize how much the industry
doesn't want to figure out the actual
answers you know suffocating having the
actual intent we do a lot of digital
buying where we're doing one mile two
mile radius media spend against specific
offer and we can show that you know
there's a uptick in foot traffic versus
your baseline and your average sale is
higher than it was before because we
clustered out other stores where they
didn't do that I mean it's you know if
you have true intent to prove the ROI
and you're lucky enough to have some
sort of transaction of some sorts or
something to anchor to even if it's a
Nielsen rating on TV which is their
currency or votes or whatever it may be
you will get the answer if it's simply
brand health then somebody's making a
subjective call no matter what report
they use as gospel
if you want yes you get yes we just had
this discussion with him we're working
on it we um one thing that was very
important to me is if this wine went
into new markets that that market didn't
pay an extra big where it was just
paying more than the American consumer
or to the best of my ability because
sometimes you've got like we're going to
Canada Canada is a mafia no country owns
the whole ecosystem you can only do so
much so we're looking at several options
I think I think I'd be surprised if we
weren't here within the next six months
dance I'm really excited about it by the
way did you guys see Gary we'll be
extinct in the UK by 2050 you see that
article there's nothing a single kid
named Gary in the UK since 1992 I'm
gonna super focus on my brand in this
region to inspire at least one
transaction real quick and I apologize
cuz is a great value I failed almost
every class I took except history and I
never ever and I mean this knew why
until recently basically the reason I
end up being right about a lot of things
is the conversation you and I just had
everything repeats itself its pattern
recognition that's right that's why
these brands are in deep [ __ ] [ __ ] if
they don't start building real brand
what they're doing that scares the [ __ ]
out of me is I think they're wasting 85
to 90 cents on every dollar they spend
on marketing doing old things with old
reports which is the only thing they can
do which is contemporary branding to
build relevance to offset the deep
technology disadvantages they're sitting
with
build brand because when this goes to
voice and I say Alexa book me a hotel I
better say Alexa book me a Marriott or
my aunt's gonna be upset
Alexa booked me a four seasons or
they're gonna be upset
because when voice becomes the Tollbooth
not search everyone's in deep [ __ ]
because with search at least you have a
prayer of seeing another result with
voice Amazon and Google pick and then
when Amazon and Google actually buy
Starwood people are very confused what's
about to happen in the world I think I'm
less confused and that's what I do
things that people make fun of and
letter later Revere so I highly
recommend if you're capable of dealing
with judgment and you have conviction to
do it it always works out at the end hi
Gracie yeah have fun I gotta run I'm
sure some people want to talk but I'm
legitimately gonna miss this
so have fun thank you so much thanks for
coming